وذلك بصواريخ بحريه مناسبه وكانت الاصابه
مباشره بفضل الله ان القوات المسلحه
اليمنيه تؤكد ان الرد على الاعتداءات
الامريكيه والبريطانيه قادم لا محاله وان
اي اعتداء جديد لن يبقى دون رد وعقاب ان
القوات المسلحه اليمنيه تؤكد استمرار حركه
الملاحه في البحرين العربي والاحمر الى
كافه الوجهات حول العالم
عدا موانئ فلسطين المحتله وان منع الملاحه
الاسرائيليه المتجهه الى موانئ فلسطين
المحتله مستمر حتى وقف العدوان ورفع
الحصار عن الشعب الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه ان
القوات المسلحه اليمنيه مستمره في تنفيذ
اجراءاتها الدفاعيه
والهجوميه ضمن حق الدفاع المشروع عن اليمن
العزيز وتاكيدا على استمرار الدعم نادي
لاخواننا الصامدين في قطاع غزه والله
حسبنا ونعم الوكيل نعم المولى ونعم النصير
عاش اليمن حرا عزيزا مستقلا والنصر لليمن
ولكل احرار الامه صنعاء السابع من رجب
1445 للهجره الموافق لل 18م من يناير
2024 صادر عن القوات المسلحه اليمنيه